Transalpheration pathway are also called the CBS pathway.
It's how you get rid of reactive oxygen species.
So that is how you make glutathione, how you make SOD.
We touched on those two things already.
How you get rid of sulfate, sulfites.
So people with defects in this pathway,
this, the CBSG can be like a break.
You have a defect in that.
You'll push this pathway really hard.
And these are the people that have issues with sulfites.
They may have issues with sulfites,
can't drink one, cause them to be all red-faced,
cause them to feel sick.
Yep, can be the sulfites in there,
can be the histamine in there.
So you'll look at this pathway.
You need to support this pathway.
They have a deficiency in glutathione.
They're not getting rid of, they're producing excess sulfites,
excess ammonia.
So people with defects here are going to produce
a lot of ammonia, especially if you have
a urea cycle defects.
That's going to cause a lot of symptoms, too.
Similar to proxy nitrate, that's not going to have
the ill-effects of causing heart disease.
And this is really causing cancer.
And to get them a lot of eukides, fatigue,
is excess ammonia production.
That's the CBSG that comes from homocysteed.
And you all remember the homocysteed
is the bottom of the sodium cycle.
That's the recycled magnesium, right?
You all got to have 100% of the testine of the game.
And then the CBSG takes it down to the glutathione and such.
So there's your ammonia symptoms.
Kind of sounds like chronic Lyme, doesn't it?
So this is where you go.
So why does I have chronic Lyme?
Because I have all these symptoms, right?
OK, there's this bacteria, and it's
called infections flowing around in your body.
How does it actually cause these symptoms, right?
What causes symptoms because it affects pathways?
And then excess things are made like proxy nitrate in ammonia.
And that's what's causing symptoms, do you understand?
So as you dig into why, why, why, why?
You keep asking that question, why?
That's where you're going to get to some base things
that you can really help a patient with.
I can't help you with your vision.
What are the symptoms?
It is growth retardation.
OK, so this is where the excess ammonia in a baby and such.
But mainly muscular fatigue, poor coronation,
just all sorts of muscle symptoms and neurological symptoms
and things like that.
Because it's better where it is.
And if it's in the muscles, you're
going to have muscle-based symptoms symptoms.
Because in the brain, you're going to have more upper border
neurons symptoms.